[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time
i'm rhett one of those friends and i'm
linked the other one of those
you just added something new come on man
this week at the round table of dim
lighting we got a lot to catch up
on my friend because we're both
fresh out of the oven of uh
wedding anniversary celebrations and uh
also like my extended birthday
celebration
oh that's what you call it which i'm
yeah i just bless you
sorry i just scatch you i think somebody
put some metal shavings in my coffee
don't question it
they taste great right you'll love them
once they take effect
the funny thing is you gave me this mug
and you here's the thing you've
never done that i was like just indulged
i said i got to make myself a coffee and
then out of nowhere like you i turn
around you're like hey use this mug and
you've never in the history
of our 35 eight i don't know how long
it's been
to your friendship you offered me a mug
and now
two sips in i'm choking on metal
shavings well they're not metal shavings
what is it what'd you do to my car they
will dissolve eventually
uh in your in your gi tract bark just go
with it
i'm trying to i just couldn't even speak
yeah i'm back from it
my anniversary may not be as many years
as yours but it's more significant
because it was 20 years and yours was 21
years you've already done 20 years
right and so i spent a week a week
and the reason we went for a week is
because jesse and i have been talking
for 10 years
about our 20-year anniversary and how it
was gonna be in italy
italy we're like so excited about italy
good luck with that
and of course uh something called covet
happened and travel is uh
hampered and so we just went to big sur
which
let me just say just went to big sur big
sur
made me better than italy i don't know i
haven't been to italy it's not called
little sir
it's called big for a reason right it's
it's living large
so i had a lot of things happen that
we'll get into i would not call it
northern cal
central central coast the central coast
of california
uh you've got redwood trees and forests
i'll tell you
all about it right to the cliff's edge
i've only driven through that i'm
freaking jealous
a little angry good um because you're
trying to kill is that why you're trying
to kill me
am i gonna am i going to die before the
end of this podcast no
good as long as i make it through this
one last release
it's just going to be for me your death
is just going to be for me it's not
going to be monetized
what if i did die before the next
podcast
would you post this one and ironically
it'd be like we joked about him dying at
the beginning of this
yes i would have to yeah i would have to
and then you know i got plenty to say so
i could probably just keep this going
where one lifelong friend talks to
himself for a long time
wow that's a good idea maybe we just
start two podcasts
maybe we just split and go with two
podcasts two lifelong friends talk to
themselves for a long time i'm sure
there's a codependency to our
relationship i just kind of avoid
knowing what that term means
because i don't want to you haven't been
in therapy long enough
all right uh but yeah i don't i don't
introduce myself to strangers as
a lifelong friend to someone who you're
not currently meeting yeah right
i've never done that who i'm currently
murdering
on a podcast for chrissy and our 20th
anniversary last year do you know what i
mean plans for us to do
go to big sur go to freaking big sur
yeah but you were in the
you were in the sick of the pandemic and
it was um
yeah it was i it was one of those times
when i thought i might still be able to
go because it was in the woods and we'd
be isolated
but it was so early that i had we had to
cancel the thing entirely
and then so much has been up in the air
i did not rebook it
until i heard that you were going to big
sur then i'm like well [ __ ] i'm not
going to big sur
the same week and actually we didn't go
anywhere for a whole week because of
like
schooling logistics and some factors at
our home
we ended up saying okay you know what
we're just gonna plan a weekend
away we're gonna christy was eyeing this
like really nice hotel
that had all this really uh fancy decor
all over the place it's like a new
design
for an and a new hotel
okay it's the kelly wurstler hotel uh
that name does seem like the one that
she was telling i just know that because
my wife is a
designer it was super cool so we just
stayed there
like basically two days two nights
almost three days
two nights and we had just like just
dedicated time together
at this hotel and i'm going to tell you
about it um we have a couple
we have a couple of little there's a
couple of things that we want to cover
before we get any further
some logistics logistics uh one thing
is we're about to take a break now you
remember you're supposed to remember
the details of this break so why don't
you well um
today we're talking about our trips next
episode
we are going to be unveiling the results
of the survey
that we gave to our wives
we have not we've not read those ahead
of time we're going to process that
next week on the show
almost a year ago we gave a survey to
our kids and got their like
just unfettered feedback so now you know
after our anniversary celebrations maybe
we buttered them up enough
well i mean uh put a pin in that well
remember to ask me about buttering my
wife up
my wife told me while we were on
vacation that she had already
completed the survey i know that's what
christie told me and i saw i don't think
that helped
so next week we're going to be we're
going to be um going through all of that
data
and seeing what we what we're going to
learn from our our wives unfettered
feedback
and then we're going to take a
three-week break no air biscuits for
three weeks
unless we decide to like re-release some
old ones just to keep the feed
alive i don't know i'm i'm soft pitching
that we'll figure that
out um i think it's not a bad idea i
it's a lot of podcasts
a little late to be figuring it out but
at least you'll have something in your
feed that maybe you haven't heard before
that's my idea if we can if we can get
um
if we can get approval if we can get
them i approve it i don't know what
you know i don't know what kiko's plate
looks like i don't want to just
yeah because we have to record some like
bookends you know like
this is an episode from 2008 and uh we
didn't have a podcast in 2008
we're in the weeds so we're doing that
so so we're going to take a three week
break or maybe it won't feel like one to
you if we follow through on this thing
but
next week the surveys uh also
latest episode of ronstadt is out man
people people loving ronstat
i mean as i speak and i don't know
what's going to happen by the time this
comes out
there's a number 11 podcast in all of
the united states
the number 11 podcast in all genres i'd
love to be able to say top 10.
well maybe it's going to be there maybe
it'll probably pop up i don't know hey
keep listening maybe that wrong stat
scripted fully immersive character
driven adventures
in this latest episode uh ronstadt
learns the spell doesn't go too well
that rhymes
okay let's get back into it i've got a
story
that i'm i'm trying to figure out if i
want to tell it
honestly like i've been going been going
back and forth
on something that happened to me uh
i guess that's the best way to put it
something that happened to me
uh i mean from a different person's
perspective it might have been
something that i something that i did
uh and i just don't know how it's gonna
make me look
so since when does that matter uh
so i don't know i let's see how this
conversation goes there's
there's i want to tell you about my trip
leading up to that too
but like i'm sitting here building it up
like a teaser but i
i have not decided oh you're gonna tell
it but if i if i do tell the story
i will say it's not for you know if any
if any children are listening they
should uh
you know maybe prepare to get educated
prepare to get educated okay don't leave
just prepare to get educated
yeah yeah i feel comfortable with that
level of warning okay
you want me to start you want me to give
you a little bit of update
um okay so i mean you know it's we're
just driving across town to santa monica
it doesn't feel like that much of a
of a trek but before we can check into
the hotel we're like
we're like oh but let's go to abbot
kenny let's go full-on hipster shopping
oh yeah
down here good spot pretty cool street
and
i realized that there was a store i was
going into this store
and it was um this the same store
that i already had the pants on do you
ever go in a store
and you realize that what you're wearing
is probably going to be on a rack
i don't like that feeling i feel like
the people there just kind of like
i don't know something about it just
doesn't feel
right it's happened a few times in
walmart for me
you know this was the former uh uh
sponsor of ear biscuits faraday faraday
yeah
ferrari everywhere i saw them all over
them i've gotten into their pants
and so not not currently a sponsor but i
was wearing the pants and i was in the
store and i was like oh
christy see these are the pants that i'm
wearing and i was kind of self-conscious
i think that's why i went ahead and just
pointed it out because i didn't want
anyone else to point it out
you're pointing it out because you think
they might think that you're like
walking out with merchandise like you're
stealing
it's just like it's just like i'm a i
may it's
it feels like something an employee
should do he's back he's desperate he's
already wearing the pants
but i'm not happy with the pants because
i always like
those pants that are a little bit short
a little bit wide they're no they're
they're
they look like jeans but they're
stretchy and softer oh yeah i mean they
kind of they kind of sell it as like it
feels like sweatpants
i wouldn't quite go that far but they
are super comfortable and i didn't take
into account the stretch
so they were i was wearing them that day
for the first time okay i'm not gonna
lie to you but i did lie to them
it was my second time okay you were
trying to return them and
out and then christy was like you're
already complaining about the pants
being a little too big because they're
stretchy why don't you just ask them to
return them and i was walking out of the
store at this point i was like you know
what
you're right screw it and i go up there
and i'm like this is kind of an
awkward kind of a thing that i'm doing
here but you know i'm wearing it
i don't know if you noticed but i'm
wearing the pants and then
we noticed this we've all been talking
about it and we thought
i was like could i exchange these for a
smaller size and they were like in the
dressing room
yeah set me up in the dressing room they
had two sizes smaller when i tried those
on
i could see the like the bottom line of
my
underwear and i'm like that's two two
sizes smaller
two sizes what's getting smaller the
waist the waist
and uh but then the thighs too and
everything gets smaller when their waist
gets smaller i guess they didn't have
the one size smaller and i was
determined you know what i need those
but i also tried on some shorts
and then i was like you know what you
can't exchange pants for shorts i'm
still gonna
exchange the pants for other pants that
they can order from me and send to my
house and i'm just going to walk out of
here in these shorts that i'm buying
you got to walk out with some pants so
now i'm wearing
my outfit has changed configurations i
went in the store with pants that were a
little too big i'm walking out with
shorts and they're short shorts and
proportions are off these shorts are
like mid
thighs short okay you might think i'm
wearing swim trunks
okay and i'm wearing these my lionel
shoes these like super
bright white tennis shoes like no socks
and then i'm wearing
a button-up shirt and my jean jacket and
i just started feeling like this is
i mean i will i wouldn't be wearing
these shorts out like this this is not
quite my con
my configuration of confidence so i
start getting in my own head about it
and christy and i are talking about it
and then we make our way back to the
hotel
and and um somebody said something about
my hair
and and it was a compliment nice hair
then somebody else
like within 20 minutes was like nice
hair
but i'm getting in my own head because
i'm like christy people are talking
about my hair
you know i i just don't think about
myself as being
like some guy who looks at sometimes you
and i will talk about it but i tend to
forget
that like oh look at that guy's hair and
now look at this guy's outfit
so i'm i mean i'm thinking about this
and chris and i are talking about it and
chrissy's like trying to characterize
what my style is and like
we're getting into it and we're going up
the elevator to the um
to the rooftop pool and there's a bar
and we were just going to check it out
because we knew that's where we're going
to be the next day
and we're like looking around and i'm
like i'm looking to see if
i don't know if just like do i fit in
here what do people think of me
it's l.a man i don't know i'm on a
banana i usually
make and it wouldn't matter i usually
don't get in my own head about this
stuff but i'm like
we had this in-depth conversation and
then i'm like
i'm looking around to see if anybody's
dressed like me
and i see this guy across the pool
lounging in a thing
and he's got on short shorts tennis
shoes
um like a a shirt and a jean jacket
and the one thing he had i didn't have i
noticed was like he had a
yellow bandana wrapped around his neck
and i'm like
i got a bandanna in my pocket i could
put that on oh no and i'm like did you
i was thinking about it and i turned to
christian i'm like well you know what
uh that guy over there is dressed just
like me
and then when i looked at him again i
realized it was harry styles
and i was like yeah i was like man i
actually you know
you stumbled into harry style i will be
yeah i'm
i guess i got harry's style that dude is
a stylish dude i mean i
i had a bandanna i'll gladly be the 43
year old version of harry styles
and i started to feel a lot better about
myself and yeah that's kind of
kind of strutted around the pool and did
my i don't my mick jagger i don't want
to take
any of the air out of your balloon at
this point but i will say that i think
that showing up to the pool wearing
exactly the same thing as harry styles
is more embarrassing than wearing the
pants into the store where you bought
them
well i mean i didn't go up to him
if you were lounging and he showed up
it's whoever's
sitting in lounging first win yeah he
was there first
in fact you should have turned around
and left at that point or at least
taking the jacket off
uh well we did wow good we did leave it
right because we were just up there
looking around when harry styles has
planted himself
at a place and you are dressed the same
you cannot sit down you have
to leave i'm you know what i'm actually
surprised i was wondering
i thought where the story was going to
go is i went up to harry styles i was
like hey look at me look at you
look at us look at me it could have
happened
i'll tell you but as much fun as i was
having the next day if he was there it
would have happened well here's a
spoiler alert he wasn't there but you
know what mission accomplished
i just humble bragged about hanging out
at the same place as harry styles and
kind of looking like it well here's the
thing man i i didn't you know we haven't
we
specifically have kept these stories
from each other good looking guy that
here from uh
from each other so that we could you
know experience them in person and
surprise one another yeah
but i i i failed to interject there's
two parallels already happening
the first thing that happened was jesse
and i stayed at two different hotels
one uh kind of in the carmel area then
the second half of the week was down in
big sur
clint eastwood was the mayor of that
team he was and i didn't see him at the
pool
but when we checked into the hotel
the bell boy bell boy was like cool hair
cool hair yeah and and and uh and jesse
was like now
jesse was like that was interesting i
think that's a you know she was like you
get complimented quite a bit
by gay men on your hair uh but that guy
seemed like he was straight and
complimented you that's like
you've just leveled up you just had
another straight dude just say he liked
your hair
the guy who uh complimented my hair was
a with a
uh a waiter could have been a busboy
straight again one of them uh i didn't
ask
good um and then the second thing
do you have a couple of minutes for a
few questions
and then the next thing that happened
was we were eating at a restaurant in
big sur
and uh a couple walked in and sat down
at the table next to us
and i was and and they had on everyone
you know this is where we're at right
now in california you walk into the
restaurant with your mask on
and then of course you take it off when
you sit down so it's a farce it's a
little bit
it's kind of theater at this point but
um
and soon to end i think but the uh
i could tell it's a farce for the fully
vaccinated let me put it to you now yeah
i could tell
with uh even with this mask on i was
like i turned to jesse and
i was like that's jon hamm john hamm
that's don draper himself
and in big sur with
the woman that he meets in the final
episode
of mad men in big sur
who they now have been dating for a few
years
okay red-headed lady the the the final
episode the
the ultimate episode the act series
finale
he is that big sir with a with a
redheaded woman
like the esselon institute which is a
real place and you're telling me
that that scene you saw in real life
because in real life the the same
redhead actress
yeah they're dating after all this time
they must have fallen in love
at the time but that was a long time ago
well now it's like 2015 when was the
last episode of mad men 2015 no clue
and then i think they started dating in
2017. so they made a connection
oh you google all this uh well of course
and then um well no jesse googled it
okay but yeah so it's like they come
back to the place where their love
was born it's beautiful it's beautiful i
was
celebrating my 20th anniversary and
seeing
you know jon hamm's love for his current
girlfriend
sorry i can't remember her name but uh
she's an actress and
so anyway but he was not dressed
anywhere close to to what i was dressed
as
in fact jessie was like interesting jon
hamm is dressed like a dad from carrie
um oh really uh carrie north carolina
pleated shorts well button-up shirt we
were in big sur so we had on a fleece i
think that was ultimately what every
but every every dude was dressed like
that like it's like you're in big sur
you don't dress up you just got on like
some a lot lodge some comfortable pants
probably with some stretch
and a fleece which i guess is how carrie
dads are dressing these days i haven't
been keeping up with carrie dad fashion
so anyway i got hair compliments and i
saw famous people too so i mean we're
even right now
okay okay i mean we could we could
we could probably like rank
everything and come out with a winner
well let me just say that harry styles
is cooler than jon hamm currently uh
and you're you were dressed like him so
i think you win that
okay and you said you got two
compliments on your hair i got one so
you're ahead right now yeah but this
isn't a competition
uh we are gonna quickly i love not
winning a competition we're going to
talk about your
shirt we've already talked about the
podcast but you know there's ronstat
merch and this is good it's a good
looking
cool ass designs going on here
look at that yeah that's the phone that
ron statt uses to
uh that he answers the weird calls the
pink phone it's got a little nickname
barbie
it's got a little uh rolling stones
homage do you have it right yep
i love it it's very cool so get one
listen to the podcast and buy the merch
mythical.com you're missing out if
you're not listening
okay uh tell me more
big sir where do i excuse me sir where
do i want to start here
um well okay
jesse had an idea um as i think i've
established before
on this podcast uh neither of us were
very happy with our wedding photos
um for multiple reasons
the key reason was the fact that i mean
you were ugly
what you look like now you're right for
some reason
i made a last-minute decision to
completely shave my face
and also to give myself a buzz cut
it was like i was going on a like a
mission to mars
you know what i mean but i was just
getting married and i kind of forgot
their pictures would be involved
needless to say i didn't look too hot
and uh
this is universally acknowledged by
everyone who's ever seen the pictures
and yeah i'll acknowledge it again you
are ugly then and jessie
uh was not happy at all
with what the choice that she had made
with her hair
oh she's always talked about that but
she didn't like a lot of the photos
we just didn't know exactly what we
wanted and
i didn't look right she didn't like her
hair so for years again we kind of built
up this 20-year anniversary thing and
one of the things that jesse has
talked about she's like you know 20-year
anniversary we'll be in italy and we'll
hire a photographer and take some
pictures on the
tuscan countryside an italian
photographer yeah
we won't even be able to communicate
we'd be using just google translate the
whole time
or we actually would just be using the
language of love and just following his
direction
anyway we were in big sur so we had to
contact a local photographer there
oh and first of all i mean this is the
most that dream didn't die one of the
most beautiful places i've ever seen
let me just say that i
love the state of california can i just
take a moment to do a little psa
uh actually i don't want you to move
here because
you know there's too many people here
already but i feel like
i'm always finding a new part of the
state which is giant
and uh i'm always finding a new part of
the state and just being like
this is remarkable i'm like i am totally
fine
that i'm basically having to give my
firstborn up to the government in taxes
because it is worth it it is worth it
it's whatever i have to pay to live here
it's worth it it's like a country in and
of itself
and yeah so many different landscapes in
big sur i mean no it might be the
pinnacle no offense to texas but i
visited there
and everybody's talking about how they
that's where they want to be it's like
they have different interests than me
well i'm with you man
hey listen move to austin i want as many
people to move to austin as possible
i like authors for multiple reasons i
like to visit but mostly because
i want the traffic to be less here uh
move the traffic to austin but anyway um
but you got a photographer big sir
incredible so
we are both and i'm thankful for this
20 years later we're both happier with
the choices that we have made
in the way that we now present ourselves
right
it goes without speaking that what i got
going on now in the facial hair
and uh hair region is significantly
better than clean shaven and buzzed
but jessie was like i know
what i want to wear and she's like i'm
going to be in big sur
and i want to have a flower crown a
flower clown
i don't know if that's the official name
for it but you know one of those things
that they wore in that i think that's
just a midsummer night
filter uh well you know the funny thing
is
is when in the last minute when she
realized that none of the florists
were speaking her language and were in a
position to make a flower crown
i was like let's just put a filter on it
and give you a flower crown and all the
pictures it was kind of joking but not
but what she ended up doing is she did
a very jessie thing which is she just
like we were sitting in a restaurant and
she walked out
to she said i'm gonna figure this flower
crown thing out and when she came back
she had a giant
basket of flowers is that somebody had
given her
a free fashion one i was like you're
going to build this thing
she's like yes and uh i'm going to show
you some pictures right well
she built the flower crown and you hot
you
you hired a photographer yeah there's
like photographers that are in the area
that it's i mean
it's very common to like get married
have anniversaries and it's
one of the most beautiful places in the
entire world okay so people do photo
shoots
it's kind of like photographers are
hanging around kind of like movers are
hanging around home depot
yeah i get it and uh like hey
can i ride in your car to your house and
i can help
like move some stuff and this guy was uh
the place we were staying
he had done this several times before
like they were like oh yes we know
we know brandon he's yeah he's a regular
here for taking photos
so anyway i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
flip through some of these photos for
you yes
and uh you're gonna make fun of me but i
i we are both what's what's very happy
what very
what's the saying uh i i know my
assignment
i knew my assignment that's what you'll
say though okay okay so we'll start with
you you get okay
you can kind of get it you get a good
idea of well the flower crown jessie
made that flower crown
well that is good you can scrub you can
relax just scroll through you need i'm
not a fan of this one and
we may not even use this one but like
you're looking
down at are you you're making sure the
flower crown does not like
i'm sniffing the flower crown making
sure it's fresh and not fake
uh let's flip through the next one you
want to see some of these
i also just want to show you some of the
scenery you're going to be blown away
jesse was ready
it hopefully you warmed up okay there
was a lot of what was he saying to you
uh he was like no now look at each other
now hold hands he was
first of all let me just tell you that's
cute if you're a photographer
direct the people you're taking pictures
of
and that's why i so appreciate about
brandon is that he was he was
he was directing us oh he was yeah he
was telling us very
we i want very specifically like you
guys are small
because those trees are huge yeah so
this property is incredible there's
redwoods all over the place
there's there's not been a direct shot
of you the whole time which i love
yeah it's like you just try to avoid a
little bit yeah just a little bit of
your face
okay there you are there's your full
face not into this one
that's not bad though
and these are just a bit these are just
the pretty face
these are just the previews that he sent
he took probably like two three hundred
pictures that we so i haven't even been
through
so i don't i can't guarantee that the
ones that link is currently looking at
are the ones that you're going to be
seeing well i can just send them from
your phone
oh look at that you're walking in a
meadow look at those trees man those are
those are redwoods
those are like those are tall
thousand-year-old redwoods right there
behind us i mean you it
really puts you in perspective you're
you're not tall compared to a red one
that's a good one right there it kind of
accentuates the height difference you
know you got jessie's dimple
very happy i think she's great i i can
still tell that you
know that your your picture is being
taken you're you're you are totally
projecting
totally projecting it i know you need to
you need to you just get oh
okay now we've got it see now you're
actually you're in the moment
you're looking at it hold on you are you
have a
complete incorrect assessment of that
photo that is a good photo
two a couple a 20 year old 20 year old
couple
a 43 year old man and a 40 year old
woman
totally in love after 20 years of
marriage that's how i interpret that
i think that one's great and then look
there's a picture of barbecue sauce now
we're talking sweet baby rose
chicken's chicken sauce actually chicken
sauce i've got some people coming over
tonight i'm making my hot chicken
sandwiches for them and then uh
i needed jesse to get some love i love
the lighting on this one that is
amazing so look at that
i can i can tell you meant that like
look at your hand
so let me get back to the blood flow is
just increased
photo shoot um mission to commemorate
out and so you know i think what we're
going to do with those
is poster size at least
30 to 40 of them and just put them all
over our house okay
all right have you ever been to
someone's home and they have a bunch of
pictures of
like themselves and like like
their wedding pictures and things like
that like we've never we've never been
into that
yeah i told christy i was like you know
it's our house is kind of like an airbnb
it's like we don't really have pictures
of like loved ones up
we have the classic pictures of the kids
going up the stairs like two
black and white photos from like five or
six years ago
uh i think that might be it i don't
think there's any
for a long time because jesse's parents
and this is funny
ironically given what i just talked
about
jesse's parents got us a giant picture
of just
jessie i think that they were very they
understood what i looked like
at the wedding um oh yeah it was just
a bridal picture of jesse we have one of
those too on a giant
really expensive frame yes one of those
things that like we were like ah
and we you know when we were first
married we had it up above
our bed above our bed too yeah we must
have talked about this
i mean it and now it's under our bed
like we still have it
but it's ours in the attic it's under
our bed ours is in the attic but i think
so we're not gonna put these pictures up
around the house i don't think
um but yeah i i uh
i was grateful i was grateful that first
because jesse was like you don't want to
do this to you i was like not really i
mean like
i i don't really like getting pictures
taken to myself i feel i've also feel
like i'm constantly
doing it with the job that we have and i
never really enjoy it
uh but i was like i know that this means
a lot to you and you know and i do
my hair is better than it used to be so
yes let's do it
you know i think it's good to it's good
to memorialize something
and also you just get to remember
the uh how tall the trees were the this
space was so beautiful
like the i gotta go the the you know
like you said the mountains coming
directly to the ocean
the only time i drove through there it
was so foggy
that i couldn't see anything well here's
the thing june
which is when we went the foggiest
month of the entire year you know the
whole june gloom thing that we get down
here as well
and they were like you guys are getting
blessed with this incredible weather
because you can see the ocean
and one of the guys uh at the hotel was
like
i've been here during june's before
where for multiple weeks in a row
i never could see more than about 20 or
30 feet yeah
the entire day it would be completely
covered in fog and so there was a couple
of mornings where it was like that where
all of a sudden it was like whoa i can't
see anything and it feels like it's
raining because of the fog condensing on
the dread woods and falling down all
over you
but yeah we got great weather i'm i'm
definitely going to go man
we may end up going by like it could
become our anniversary place i don't
know
but i doubt it you know there's other
places to go yeah there is man
it's california think about all that
stuff you just bragged about right yeah
there's always a new place to find but
yeah it might be the pinnacle
you know i i i will i would have loved
to have had a week for chris and i to
have
uh you know to to get away and and
we'll do that in due time but i will say
you know we packed
so much fun into just like a couple of
nights away
that i just i we were talking we were
sitting the next day we were sitting by
the pool and like you got these like
lounge chairs and
that's where that's where harry was on
the on the opposite side
but then behind me in a special section
no
it was a then there was a there's like a
bar over here
and then there's like these big circular
couches like semi-circular couches
and they called them cabanas and i mean
they would have like a
uh an umbrella over top of it and then
like a little table in the middle
so it wasn't to me a cabana is like a a
covered tent like thing
that you could and you can lay down and
be out of the sun
right but this was more of like a couch
situation
and but since there were only two of us
we probably could have had
two four six eight people four couples
in this thing
but we had reserved the thing for like
four hours
because you know we don't we don't like
to be obligated to be in the sun the
whole time and we want to be over there
and we could have table service like it
was really nice
like we had uh somebody come take our
order and like we were eating and
drinking
man we were having a good time over
there
and um and so you're so you're sitting
there
and again i'm kind of thinking like
i'm i'm getting i'm getting getting good
at
at going to like these high falutin
places and having a good time this is
what i'm telling christy i'm like
you know what i know i was in my head
yesterday about what i was wearing and
do i fit in but like you know what screw
it today is my day
this cabana is my cabana and the world
is my oyster
and i'm wearing my like my trucker hat
and my sunglasses my hair is coming out
and i'm like
i got my shirt off and my shoes off and
i'm laying down on this
couch and the other people i noticed
when i would like go to the bathroom or
something
uh i'm just gonna call them rich [ __ ]
okay yep right okay i'm just gonna you
know i don't
i don't i mean to offend anybody i don't
think you can
find a rich [ __ ] you got these like
every other thing they're okay
every other table was just you know just
a covey of
rich [ __ ] just sitting there
um with their posture yeah and they're
like
outfits and their axe up and they're
just talking
they're just talking about you know at
first
i just i was like i don't know how i got
myself into this but like
i knew i was gonna feel nauseous but i
didn't want to throw up because
i think it's part of the process and
like
you know we made our way all the way out
here and come on
and she's like where and so but then
after a while i just had to vomit
i just had to vomit yeah and i mean
i just can't even get into what was
happening around me and so it's like
all these rich [ __ ] talking about i
don't know they're like
they're peyote excursions and like uh
right
it was a trip and
meanwhile and you know when they're all
like prim and proper and put together
and with their drinks
and then anybody who walks by the next
booth is like
like basically picturing my dad sprawled
out
at myrtle beach like that was me and
christie and i was like you know what
we are having a good time and christy's
like
yeah you are yeah yeah you are you just
said this was your cabana
she was like i'm also present she was
like i don't think
i don't think you're supposed to bring
your own lacroix to the table
and i was like well i wasn't finished
with it and then she's where'd you get
the lacroix from
from the room because we had brought our
own drinks to the room
interesting um definitely cold brews
definitely some toppo chicos and some
lacroix i gotta have all that stuff and
like
late at night i gotta i gotta be
hydrated
true like i drink i have a topa chico by
my bed and a lacroix
and a cold brew man so yeah i was
bringing one to the pool side because i
wasn't finished with it and she's like
you also didn't have to bring your own
music they are playing music here
you were playing open-air music like i
had one of those like
beats pill things because their music
was it was quiet
and it wasn't good enough and i and i
did walk around i r
and i this is that was that's probably
they couldn't hear my music at the other
booth
the rich [ __ ] were not hearing my
yacht rocks well the more you talk the
more i think you might be the rich [ __ ]
i mean we might need to flip the script
on we had so much fun
like the the we were just having the
best time the waitress would come up to
our table and like christy would just
start talking to her
i guess she was uh you know she had
talked to me enough or maybe i talked at
her enough i don't know i was like
you know how when i have a good time i
get kind of talkative yeah
um i was gonna read a book i was to
listen to some
music i was going to listen to some
podcasts like we just talked
like four hours straight except when the
waitress comes up and then christy's
like
talking about harry and megan
and i'm like oh lord don't take the bait
the waitress
starts it or no christie starts and
she's like are you into this
harry and megan and you know their their
new their new
baby are you into it i'm like listen
don't
don't get sucked into this and then she
starts talking about princess diana and
i mean
all of this stuff and like we're having
this like detailed conversation with
this woman and she's
the waitress the waitress is into it
because she's
serving all these rich [ __ ] who don't
even look at you
i'm like i'll take them i'll take
another
uh so and so what in and out spritzer
right yeah you know oh
i'll have one of those too yeah and
let's go to the bathroom together you
know i don't know
i don't know what they're doing are
there any men uh
no not many men around okay
all right they were probably all
somewhere else i didn't care i didn't i
didn't care about seeing other men
after seeing harry i was good yeah
but yeah i mean i i'm just like i'm
gonna have a good time and you know what
we're coming back here
and we're bringing friends and we're
gonna show everybody how this is done
you'll be invited well the funny okay um
again the parallels are pretty striking
you had a pool
uh there was a pool at this hotel um
there were actually multiple pools i
mean chris and i took pictures of each
other
well okay so you know we
having not decided to go to italy and
being not able to go to italy
we and this is our 20-year anniversary
we're like we're going to splurge
okay okay so uh
this is probably the nicest place we've
ever stayed i would say easily the
nicest place we've ever stayed
and so at the it each
every single room is like its own
house essentially not house but i mean
like we were in like a cabin we were in
like a tree
it was literally a tree house a like
built in a tree
it went rubbed in the trees and it had
stairs that went to it so it wasn't
like the tree was coming through the
middle and like they had put it on posts
or whatever but it was called the tree
houses
part of this it was elevated amongst
trees yeah and it was
incredible uh but there were also like
some like hobbit house type things that
are like built into the side of the
slope and have grass growing on top of
them
it's just an incredible place super
creative approach to the architecture
and everything and the way it all blends
in the whole idea is that
it looks like you're just kind of just
ascending into the redwoods right
they thought of everything and at each
end of the sort of this line of
cabins um is a what they call a
meditation pool which
what us from harnett county call a big
hot tub
and a big hot above ground and uh it's
it's
it's beautiful though it's like an
infinity edge hot tub it's like 102
degrees
and on each side of the resort they're
and this is a small resort so there's
literally only
eight chairs at each pool oh this is a
small
thing oh right so there's like four sets
of two chairs at each
each end and then there's another pool
that's a bigger pool that's in a
different space but these are the ones
that are like right on the edge so
that's where most of the people would go
and
again that was never full i mean it was
like there was one time where all eight
chairs were full that was the fullest it
got it wasn't like people were coming up
and getting turned away
but there was a moment where okay when
when the pool is that small when it's
just a big hot tub
and there's only eight chairs there
there's a choice that is made
which is are we going to converse with
the other people sitting here
it's not like a big pool that you you
were at where it's like you're kind of
just everybody sort of hanging with
themselves
it's like i'm kind of right next to this
other couple and if we're there's two
couples here
do we start talking and if we start
talking when do we stop talking
yeah does this conversation go on
forever
well we had had a good conversation with
like two other couples
and kind of like found out what people
did for a living and just kind of
connected
at one pool but then the next day we're
at this other other side
and there was another couple there that
was
kind of given off that we're keeping to
ourselves vibes and so we were like
we're keeping to ourselves as well i
mean that's what we were going to do
so i'm like reading a book a book that i
would recommend at the end of this
and then um
speaking of rich [ __ ] and i and i
believe that that term can apply to both
men and women oh hell yeah
um a couple comes in and
um the dude like
i mean this is like everyone's being
kind of quite it's a quiet peaceful
place you feel like you're in the woods
and it's just like this dude walks in
he's like hi guys
the way that jesse described it later is
like he came in like i'm here now
and he's like i am present you know and
i was like
hey you know i just gave a little bit of
a hay and
so like he sits down with his uh female
companion a wife girlfriend
partner or whatever and he had a wife a
girlfriend and a partner
i mean just one woman and there and they
sit down
and then he's like oh no
i forgot my sunscreen and i'm looking at
his wife who is currently applying
sunscreen to herself
and she says well just use this and he's
like
i don't use that it's chemicals he
didn't say
i don't i don't use that it has
chemicals he said i don't use that
it's chemicals which i thought was an
interesting
choice of words yeah he's a beat and i
was like okay all right
when you splurge on a place like this
the clientele no i like you
you're just kevin you're you're gonna
this is great you're gonna get some
interesting characters
he might be a friend i'm not going i'm
not going well stay tuned
because the next thing he does is i
guess he had just determined that he
didn't need his sunscreen
he walks to the edge of the hot tub at
the top of the steps
again this is a beautiful i've said it
already it's a beautiful spot it's the
most beautiful hot tub i've ever seen
infinity edge hot tub i mean come on
right looks like it goes 1200 feet above
sea level you write it
you get it the right angle where it
stops the ocean begins
and then he gets to the edge and before
he steps in he places
both hands over his heart and just goes
and this is everyone can see in here
it's loud this dude is doing like a
cleansing breath
like right before he gets into the hot
tub this is me dude
i i i think this is going to be me well
no
i hope not because i'm not going to the
hotel with you if this is you the deep
breathing
he then steps into the water and i'll
admit
the water feels good and they adjust
they had obviously
just arrived at the hotel like this
first thing they're doing they're
getting in they got in the room they
come to the hot tub
so they're experiencing this all for the
first time i remember my first time
that's not the first thing i do when i
get to a new place
and then he steps into the water
and all of a sudden he's just like going
ah this guy was having an
orgasmic experience in the hot tub the
hot water was doing things for him
the hot water is never done for me oh
yeah
oh oh oh and then he begins to speak
french
it was like something about exposure to
the hot water flipped him into french
mode and he began speaking french to his
wife who begins speaking french back to
him
there's a french conversation that
happens about i don't know i took three
years of french but i didn't pick up on
any of it but i assume it has to do with
how awesome the hot tub was
jim i know the words for green beans and
[ __ ] he gets
out of the hot tub walks back to his
wife and begins speaking
english again so there's something about
the hot tub that brings the french out
in this man
um and i gotta say as much as i was
judging him
in the moment the more i've reflected on
it i'm like
i think this guy's living his best life
that's what i'm saying yeah
that's what i'm trying to do man well
and you know what i had a lot you need
to learn how to do it in
not such a pretentious way well so we're
sitting here it was a little
it was a little imposing i got an i got
a story that goes just
with this and i think that i judged it
one way
and now because of your story and what
you just said i'm seeing it another way
well we were sitting at our booth we're
just hanging out we're we're looking out
on the pool but like there's some things
that
give us we have more privacy except
there's these two chairs that are kind
of in front of us
in a little table where some people
might wait until one of the
the big cabanas opens up and
um this man sits down there faces away
from us
and he's just sitting there right but
then all of a sudden
his his wife comes over now she could
have been french
i never heard them speak and she sits in
the chair
across from him and so she's looking
over his shoulders
at us you know definitely jealous of the
good time that we're having right
i mean that's got to be clear um
and then she gets up and comes over
and i don't know how else to say it
she the the seat that the guy was in was
kind of like it reclined back a little
bit
like you know at maybe a 30 degree angle
it was almost an adirondack chair
she comes over and mounts them like one
knee
straddle one knee on one side under his
armpit kind of
other knee on the other side and her
feet on the chair and so she's like
like like as if he was a squatty potty
like her feet and heels are on the sides
of his hips
and then she just like rests on him
lowers down and then she like
closed so they're fully clothed yeah but
i mean she mounted him
right and we know what will happen and
he's kind of on his phone and she's kind
of like
kissing his ear and stuff and chris is
like well well well and i'm like
well i mean she knows we're here so i'm
just gonna watch
and i was like and so i just kind of
propped up on my left shoulder
and i mean she's as far from i am from
that camera
like where that i mean what was that six
feet set maybe we're not even seven feet
from each other okay and i'm just
i'm just like seeing what's gonna happen
right
but she sees me and then i feel like
okay
this now this is part of it she's she's
mounted him but she's looking at me and
i'm looking at her
and i'm seeing who's going to look away
first or
basically i felt like i felt like she
shouldn't been mounted him right now in
front of me because it distracted me
from my good time
what was the expression on her face when
she looked at you it was kind of like
yes i'm mounting him it was blank would
you like to be him it was
blank it was blank okay so i was like
who i think this is
a battle i'm not gonna look away until
she gets
until she dismounts don't believe it was
a battle that's weird but
okay did it work um
no and in retrospect you know what
i should have done it totally
differently you should have mounted
christie i should have just
kept looking right at her i should have
just no i just should have mounted
christy or vice versa
or i should have just been like that's
awesome it has nothing to do with me
why am i acting like this is like
cramping my style
like because i felt i felt like i'm
like you're doing a lot of thinking all
the fun that i'm having
all of a sudden goes out the window
there's a lot of thinking going on i
need to be doing the pda and not judging
other people's pda or the pdo as well i
gotta say
freaking i just gotta freaking go with
it yeah you know
and i gotta like em i gotta get in the
pool and deep breathe and just
no you gotta breathe before you speak
french
i had another that's my one regret is
that i i had animosity towards this
this woman i know you got your story and
then i've got something out this is
gonna be a longer one guys
uh but quickly i want to tell another
funny interaction we had
shout out to the mythical beasts that we
ran into while hiking
ah on a beautiful beautiful path
uh but after jesse and i did a hike
through
the redwoods to like a perch where you
could kind of see
for miles we go back down to
um looking for a bathroom
and uh there was like a restaurant and
gift shop you know everything's kind of
in that is it open is it not open but
most things are open now
in california so uh we're approaching
this gift shop restaurant situation
and a woman
middle-aged woman who's alone comes up
to us
and she's like uh excuse me are there
restrooms in there
and i was like um well we haven't been
in yet but
i i'm assuming that there's restrooms in
there because it's a restaurant and a
gift shop so yeah i think i think
there's probably restrooms in there
without saying anything to me she turns
away from me
and suddenly into the woods she's like
what and then she turns back to me and
says thank you
she spoke crow either this woman is
traveling with a crow
i don't know if it's a single crow or a
pack of crows and i don't know if that's
the correct
murder a murder of crows or this woman
is using crow cause to communicate with
her
companions her family i guess um
that beats french i'll tell you the
funny thing is is like you're in the
it's one thing to use a crow call like
when you are
like in the middle of the city or you're
in a place where like a crow call is
going oh that that's a mom doing her
crow call but you're in the woods where
there are crows doing crow calls
and this is a really good crow call it
sounded real was she dressed like hippie
she was dressed like a mom ready to take
on a mountain okay
you know what i'm saying there's there
was there was a wide-brimmed hat
oh very okay very expensive sunglasses
tank top cargo
shorts maybe hiking boots what happened
next i just went in and used the
bathroom
i think she waited on the crows to show
up i don't know you didn't even see
what i was like hanging around like all
the children like run out of the woods
you felt you felt sure it was going to
be children
well i just thought that she's
communicating with her family that's
odds
bird language i mean the things you
experience when people spending way too
much money
i think that's what you know no but this
was just this was at the state park
oh oh this goes into the hotel you do
you think kids are allowed at the hotel
last day that
is my 20-year anniversary oh yeah i
don't want to see a child and if i do
i'm going to throw them in the ocean
it's a long last thing i want to do is
see anyone under 18.
i mean there's nothing there's nothing
like a kid that'll ruin a good time
just keep that in mind if you haven't
had any yet yeah i had a woman mounting
a man
and that somehow ruined my moment yeah
because just because
i mean because she was thinking about
making children just the thought of that
couple of making children turned you off
i gotta really work on the pda
um don't start with a mouse all right
let's work your way up to it i
you know what we don't have time i'm not
gonna tell the story cole come on you're
telling the story man
listen man i'm just gonna be i'mma tell
it like it happened okay
and i don't know how it's gonna make me
look but
i'm i mean i'm just i'm i'm human and
i'm just don't give anything i'm being
honest don't get any disclaimers just
tell yourself and this is what happened
speak your french man uh i've told a lot
of massage
stories on your biscuits i consider
myself a
professional massage receiver
like i'm i can be cr i could be the best
critic of massages i'm on record saying
that could be my next career
a a like a massage
and spa consultant somebody who comes in
and i need to start a patreon for that
because i don't know if you're going to
get paid directly by anyone except your
patrons um i know when it's good i know
when it's great
i know when it's bad i've had them all
i thought oh but we were going to this
place and they had a spa
and yeah this place is pricey and i'm
like you know what we are go
we're going to splurge let's get let's
get massages here and then
um christy was looking into it and she's
like these are pricey massages this is
kind of
this is this is going to be the most
expensive massages we've ever gotten
right
and then she told she texted me at work
one day and she was like
uh i got you an appointment but they
didn't have one from me i'm on a waiting
list and i'm like why
no you take it i don't you know
i she's like you're much more into
massages than i am
um so i want you to do this this is part
of your
birthday and i'm just i'm not nearly as
into massage as you are and i knew this
was true
so i didn't argue anymore i was like you
know what i will accept this gift
and so we spent all day by the pool
i kept forgetting that i was having the
massage and christy would remind me
that like oh you can't forget we got
this you got to be down there for the
massage at five i'm like oh yeah
massage
and so i get down there and
i did know that this was going to be
unlike any other massage not just
because it's the most expensive
but because this was the first time i
was ever going to get
a four-handed massage oh
wow four hands two people could have
been four hands four people would one
hand tied behind their back i didn't
know
and you didn't care but i assumed it was
two and okay so it was
and it was it was two women i show up
there you know
um i'm not weird
at a spa i'm good at this like i mean
with
you can't do all the other spa stuff
because the covid restrict like you
can't go in early and like do the hot
tub or like
chill out somewhere you're just go
you're going in there you're going in
the room you're going to get massage
like a
like a normal place but like i know how
to like make eye contact
and say that you know listen to what
they're saying about the massage and not
be weird
okay definitely not creepy like
i'm a pro and this is a this is a this
is a thing
you sound like you're giving yourself a
little bit of a pep talk just
it's just like you're saying somebody
going to the proctologist like he sees
buttholes all day i mean yeah this guy's
not going to think anything's weird
about my boy she's buttholes all day
right
no she was like okay so they start
orienting me this
they said the name of the massage and
they only had like six massages and they
all had like weird names
as if i had been transported to india
yeah and and um she was like so we're
gonna we're gonna start with the
treatment called the so-and-so
and are you fine with getting having oil
in your hair
and i'm like oh yeah i'm i'm totally
getting i've got cool hair because i i'm
totally good
you guys have told me that i'm totally
uh i'm like that sounds great
and and then she's like and
uh we're gonna be putting oil on your
body and then
for this and then for the second
treatment which is called something else
that i can't remember or couldn't
pronounce
uh is when we're gonna go into what i
knew would be the
the drip experience where they drip
hot oil on your forehead
and that's all i knew they said okay so
um
we'll we'll leave the room there's a
there's a restroom in the room
there's through those doors it's just
your restroom and then you've got this
room here
which is the massage room we'll step out
for you to get undressed you get
completely undressed and then
lay down face down on the table and take
this towel
and drape it over your your backside
right
okay yeah i've done all this before i'm
absolutely
like this is nothing new and you got to
get naked you got to get naked for i
mean
absolutely just for those of you who are
who are
you know you're still self-conscious
about you got to get completely naked
when you and there that's what they're
expecting you to do when you go get a
massage
it's not sexual is you just you you get
naked
and then they you're covered in all the
right places and that's part of it right
put don't leave your underwear on no um
and you know what they clear
they even said that so it was like it
all off yeah
now there wasn't a sheet like a lot of
places you get under a sheet and then
they'll like manipulate the sheet
they just had a towel and i would i
would call it a hand towel
okay it's not real big it wasn't it was
just a hand towel
and for hands how big
a normal hand towel i'm holding up the
dimensions for you can tell the people
what that
length is i don't know okay or the 16 by
10. okay thank you
um so yeah they leave i get dressed
i take a leak because i always get
anxious that i'm gonna need to pee
during a massage and nothing ruins a
massage like having a pee bad
especially if you have to get up in the
middle and go pee and like you then
that's have you done that
number of minutes i've done it once
where like i couldn't hold it and then i
had to get up in the middle of the damn
thing
i i pee i get naked i lay down face down
i put the
i mean the towel it felt small i mean i
got a little ass
but the towel felt small and so i draped
it sideways
and then i wait and i start doing my
deep breathing
mm-hmm just to totally get like
in a zone speaking french for yourself
of relaxation
just a week they knock on the door they
come in they come in
and um yeah i was like wow four hands
how is this gonna work
and then they start by pouring
oil like copious amounts of
oil all over my back my legs
everything but before they did that two
people two people
before they did that they took the towel
that i had put
two women two women and they had put you
know i had the
the hand towel horizontal across my butt
cheeks
so the first thing they did when they
walked in was they
took the towel and rotated it 90 degrees
so then it was it was draped between my
legs
and then up to the small of my back
because you need the sides of your
glutes exposed they need access
yes so they so then my cheeks were
exposed
yeah including the one that like
says christy and a nice crisp cursive
tattoo
right that made me feel better
you know it's like i've definitely got
the i've got the label
i'm taking again i'm not i'm not
thinking about it it might be an old
relationship
i'm just thinking but they're not
they're not thinking about that
of course of course not they're not
thinking about it i actually wasn't
either all i was thinking was
are four hands better than two well i
would think so and then there are six
are better than four they're on
each side and they and i did notice they
didn't ask
any of the typical questions like do you
have
there was no forms to fill out do you
have any injuries what type of pressure
do you want
they're gonna find that out with their
hands they they didn't ask me
to give them any direction because
this was a process and then they start
like they're rubbing my feet and it's
like
you know two hands on one foot two hands
on the other foot i'm like okay
i get twice as much foot massage in the
same amount of time this is cool
um and then they start
pouring the oil everywhere they're like
pouring it seems like they're pouring
all out of buckets with holes in the
bottom
and it's like trickling all over my
whole body and it feels
absolutely amazing i doubt it was a
bucket but and then
there they they start
in my back and they held my hand with
one hand
and then with the other hand they would
massage my back so one hand they weren't
using at this point and i'm thinking
just holding your hand yeah just
comforting just to nut like pushing down
on my hand just you remember there's two
of us
there's two of us here and each of us is
only using one hand
going up your back and around your spine
and they did what i would describe as a
synchronized hand dance on my back well
i would hope so
and it and i was thinking you know what
i love really deep pressure
this is nowhere near that this is a
totally different thing
this is a this is like a relaxation
there's like a performance yeah
this is cirque du soleil this is almost
like it's it's about the two of them
coordinating and doing something and
proving to me how in sync they can be
it's almost like i don't even need to be
here right but but i began to say okay
i'm disappointed maybe i could be
disappointed that i'm not getting any
pressure
and because but you'd never say that i
like the pain of a massage
there was no pain it was only it just
felt good but it was also the
fascination that like they were putting
their fingers in between each other's
fingers and going up my back and like
and then they would move apart and go up
and down my back and it was
all completely coordinated so like
and i could tell that one of them was
the leader and one of them was the
follower but they were like almost in
sync
and so i was kind of into this as like a
show right kind of a thing it was like
um and then they're like dumping more
oil on me
and i i mean i'm like i'm not a slide
off this table like i've never
i could be part of it inundated with so
much while you are on the floor
and then it's and you know i'm just
laying there with my face in the
in the donut and then they start doing
this
massage that goes from my shoulder
in sink all the way down over my
butt cheeks and my hips and down to my
legs and just back and forth
oh yeah this was the first point that a
thought crossed my mind
that this might be too good this might
be there might be
there might be an issue here
i was like this might be yes
link might not be ready for this one
this might be the
himself the professional massage
receiver may have reached his limit
and but it's just a thought it's just a
thought going through my head
it's a tiny thought and i'm like breathe
deep so i breathe deep
and i'm like i'm used to the pain at
this point like
if if those type of thoughts cross my
mind in a massage
they immediately go away because i'm in
so much
pain which is a form of pleasure to me
but it's like it's a therapeutic sport
treatment type situation yeah being
devoid of any pain
i'm like this is uncharted territory
right um but it is nice
and so and then the the the massage
up and down my entire body um
turned into like fingernails
wow back of the scratching all the way
down my body
in a light fashion and i'm like
i feel like we're approaching
the flip
yeah why am i telling this that could be
this could be a tricky situation why am
i telling this
um just because it happened you're
telling it now it's because
you've committed and we are publishing
this again i'm i'm a pro with the flip i
know what's up
it's like they're like okay we're going
to um we need you to slide down
further down the table and then when
your head is on the actual table and not
in the doughnut part
then we want you to roll over face up
and do they both get on one side during
the they're on either side and they
that's tricky they picked up the towel
whoa and they like held the towel
and then um i didn't really look at them
i don't i don't look at them
well when but i was the only time to
look i i saw them out of the corner of
my eye and they were looking away
you know it was it was looking into the
corner they were looking into the corner
and they were holding the thing it was
they're professionals they've done this
before i mean yeah they didn't like
sneak in
yeah right before this started and say
hey let's do this two-handed thing
so then so so i roll over and they and
they
they put the thing back down and then
they they take the towel and they rotate
it again
vertical so it's draped in between my
legs and then
it's going that this way okay up to the
belly button
right and
i'm cool they're they're they're
starting with the feet
and i'm doing some deep breathing and
it's like this is this is a reset
you know this is a reset whole new side
nothing other side of the burger
nothing yeah there was uh
i was not i was not saying doing or
presenting anything that would cause
alarm
you know okay i was playing it cool yeah
and um then they started you know
then they're pouring the oil everywhere
and like i'm it's like i'm going through
all the synchronicities and all this
stuff is happening again it's like this
is cool
but then they start doing on the top
side what they were do
what they were doing earlier on the
bottom side they did a few up and downs
all the way
and then um the girl
i shouldn't say the the professional
masseuse woman right
she wasn't a girl right she was a female
anyway
she goes she starts massaging my scalp
yeah both hands just like full-on
massaging my scalp
it feels good amazing and i'm like where
where's the other woman gonna go the
other professional masseuse
and she goes to my
stomach okay this is new
and i'm like first of all i never maybe
once ever have i had anybody massage my
stomach and i think i was like
i'd be laughing at this point it was
like ticklish it was not ticklish
because there was so much
oil okay barely
and she's like she's like rubbing my
belly
and then rubbing up my chest and i
i mean i really felt like i was in some
game of thrones scene yeah some like
that's what i was thinking
something's it's like there's like a
like a
medieval like people rubbing on you type
situation i mean this is i
i i was blindsided i really i mean
i got in a preview face down but now
here i am and i'm just breathing deep
and i'm like you know what
i i i'm gonna
i'm gonna be cool with this i'm gonna be
cool that might be the wrong thing to
think at this point
i'm just gonna breathe deep and i'm just
gonna you know i'm just experiencing
this
this this the most expensive
professional massage i've ever had in my
life
and about the price think about how much
you're spending and i'm like well and
i'm like i am thinking things like
okay there's a central component to this
but i know that this is a totally
legit spot you know yeah this is
absolutely professional
there's there's no chance of any
hanky-panky
situation happening like i knew that
that was not going to happen correct
and i took comfort in that we are all
professionals here
right i'm a professional receiver yeah
professional givers
and but then they both got on either
side of me and they started at the top
and they did the rub the rum rubbed down
across the hips all the way down to the
bottom
and then it they started with the
fingernails
i mean like and okay
at this point i i by the way the entire
time that
i'm i flipped over i have a blindfold on
i bet i have i have a napkin or a towel
or whatever you want to call it
draped over my face i was blindfolded
okay
the whole for this whole thing right and
at that point i definitely
i could tell that like
something had moved the towel oh my
god oh no i mean
i just and it wasn't one of them it
wasn't one of
it it was of the six hands
that were involved in this professional
exchange oh my gosh
no hands moved the tower right yeah it
was almost like magic i might say
and uh it wasn't
it wasn't like uh like
the towel was tossed off the table or
anything yeah right
or that the towel like it wasn't a
tenting situation
no it wasn't a tinting situation it was
a sh it was like a shifting
yeah just a slight shift yeah totally
normal
and at this point i'm just like
i was petrified well yeah literally
well um yeah i was uh
i guess petrified is the best word but i
mean i was i would say i was
i was half petrified yeah yeah i get it
okay yeah yeah i get it
i get it yeah this is a natural cycle
and i didn't you know just happened
i panicked and i was like i need to flip
back over
is there another flip but but i just
what i
what i did in that in that moment what i
decided to do was just
play it cool and just breathe through it
i was breathing that loudly at this
point like i was like i hadn't been
doing that and like all of a sudden i'm
like
oh just like i like that guy entering
the spa the french dude
right and like i could tell that like
their hands
stopped and then they they both went to
the feet
oh they know about that they had some
training yeah moved to the feet and i
was like okay
brilliant we're still all on the same
page here this is just
we're going to all play this cool so you
think they they were responding to you
definitely it was in a it i would i
wouldn't call it abrupt
but for like the professional
methodical movements of a masseuse it
was an abrupt change in
in uh in location from being at the
sides of the hip
to being down both down at the feet
because this has to be a very common
occurrence and so let me just tell you
what happened at that point so then
there was like
there was like 10 minutes more of a
massage it wasn't over it wasn't like
up excuse me it wasn't like a siren all
right yeah
and they opened the door and they kicked
my ass out give him a refund
uh it was professional and
and gracious redirection of attention
and then when that when that was winding
to a close
um she came up to my ear again i'm still
blindfolded and she was like
link before we
before we go to the next part of the
treatment
um would you like to use the restroom
and i yeah your eyes are getting huge
right now under the blindfold my eyes
got huge and i was like
is this just procedure or is this is
this a special accommodation
are there some expectations that now i'm
supposed to meet
my mind is is going like 100 miles an
hour and i'm like
i could hear myself like trying to form
works
i was like uh no i'm fine and by the way
i don't understand the question
well it was it was an hour and a half
the whole thing
and yeah potentially anyone at a certain
it was a break in the
you think this question i think this
question is asked to everyone i don't
think i mean because i don't but i
definitely
interpret it as do you need to take care
of anything
yourself what's going to the restroom
going to do
well you know just have some privacy to
i don't you know just uh i don't know
blue balls man but i thought i i
had i had fully recovered at that point
yeah i think i was totally recording i
think this is just this that was it
it's just a procedure everybody just
procedure but i'm i was reading way into
it i don't even
even noticed anything i had a second
well that's an insult
then we moved to the so then it turns
out they had a good number of stuff to
set up while i was like
just laying there and like meditating
and then they just bring out this
again i was i had the thing over my eyes
but they
they brought this thing and they started
dripping oil on my
on the center of my forehead and
sometimes they would move it to one side
or the other
and it was at least 30 minutes of just
oil
yes just oil dripping on my forehead
that's why they asked you to use the
bathroom
and once you start dripping on somebody
and it was very
it was very meditative and it was really
cool because like whenever your mind
would wander
you could recenter by focusing on the
fact that
like oil was being drilled into your
head like i guess like water torture
but in a good way so that was cool and
then when that was over we were you know
we were on speaking terms and on
speaking sorry it was uh
it was fine but like uh i get back to
the room and we had like 20 minutes
before our dinner reservation so i'm
like getting ready very fast i'm like
but i could not wait to tell christy
what had happened
okay well yeah so she already knows this
she's not finding out now
there's no way in hell i'd be telling
this story if i hadn't told her first
but like i was just like i don't know
what happened to me i have to tell you
about this we have to process
this and like we're sitting in the lobby
waiting for our table and like i tell
her the whole story and she's like
googling like
erection while um getting a massage
is totally common and sometimes you just
can't control it and it happens
and i will say that i i you know
i didn't i didn't have a i understand
okay
you've been clear there was not a
tensing situation okay yeah this was a
this was just uh a slight but she was
changing
she thought it was hilarious but she was
also super sweet
and like like reassuring me that like
i'm not a
i'm not a freak or a creep well i could
have told you that you didn't have to
look that up on google man
listen i didn't look it up on google i
didn't want that to be my history is
just think about it for a second you're
being
it's not it doesn't mean anything yeah
you're being touched
it doesn't mean anything and you're
naked
yeah i'm totally fine with it i have no
shame
associated it's a common thing they see
they see this
yeah this was like the fourth one of the
day the one thing
especially with that particular massage
right of course um
the one thing that we did read was that
like you know you can say something
that's like
that acknowledges what you're going
through
and not apologize but like acknowledge
like and it might sound kind of like an
apology but you definitely don't want to
say anything that's like
it can be self-deprecating but it can't
be something that could be misconstrued
as flirtatious
like oh i guess i guess you made him
happy
you know it's like that's obviously
that's what the website say you'd never
say
i didn't say anything and i would never
say anything like that but that is
what what christine and i were that's
what she was reading to me was like you
know what you could have just
what their advice is just to acknowledge
it and then move on
and you might say or you might suggest
sorry
i could go you know i might need some
more i might need to flip back over or
something you know it's like
you've got a lot to think about
it's an embodiment uh exercise
to say you know what these things happen
and it doesn't have
i mean and there's a there's a right way
to deal with it
and a professional and appropriate way
to deal with it
that there shouldn't be shame involved
in it and that's actually why i'm like
you know what i'm going to tell this
story because it's it's hilarious to go
through
but it's also it's just a thing that
it's the thing that is
happens to the best of us um
well i've got one more story that's a
pretty wild shift in uh tone
okay okay but why not
since we've already let's do it we've
already tinted or semi-tinted
um the uh so one of the things
that we decided to do there was a lot of
different activities a lot of things you
could sign up for
and one of the things that jesse and i
decided to do
on our final day was a forest meditation
right oh yeah and there's a part of me
that was like we're in big sur
let's just do let's do the weird stuff
right now i mean obviously i i meditate
regularly and like a forest meditation
is not something that's like
you know 10 years ago it would have been
like oh this is real dumb and i'm just
going to do it for fun and now it's like
i'm i'm going into it with an
expectation of like this could be really
cool and you know yeah
um four-handed forest massage right now
meditation
but uh i want to you know i want to talk
a little bit about
a sort of a realization and sort of
something i'm grateful for
that kind of came out of this process so
forest meditation is kind of probably
what you might be imagining it is there
was it was just two couples it was us
and another couple and then this
woman who was leading the meditation and
she kind of takes you
through the path through the forest and
you like pick a leaf
and she's like i'll take this leaf with
this bay leaf off of this
thing and kind of crush it in your hands
and smell it and she's like let's
meditate on that and then you kind of
walk into
this place where there's the redwood
grove and she begins to talk about
the nature of the way redwoods grow
where there's like a grandmother tree
they call it in the middle and then
there's a conce there's concentric
circles of younger trees
yeah just the way they grow and they're
all connected through their roots and
they're connected to other trees through
their roots that are
all supporting one another that's how
they kind of stand up because
the roots grow very horizontally because
of the way the bedrock is in places
where redwoods grow
and so they're literally holding each
other up and they're also sending
nutrients to one another
yeah you know cool tree stuff
and there was some i mean so she was
kind of giving some nature information
but then it would also be like all right
we're going to close our eyes and we're
going to like
we're sort of leading a meditation and
i'm sure you can relate to this uh but
one of the things that
is sort of a constant for me
at this point in my life is that you
know having grown up as
you know in the south in a conservative
christian place
as a conservative christian as an
evangelical christian
and not being that now there's always
that sort of
the old rhett that's kind of present in
my mind that when i'm experiencing
something that's very typical sort of
california new age
forest meditation yeah the old rhett is
kind of like
their sort of judging
and kind of almost making fun of the new
rat that is experiencing this thing that
the old rep would have just
laughed at and thought was ridiculous
right yeah like this is so funny that
you're doing this forest meditation this
is kind of dumb i mean it's just a tree
man
right yeah that voice gets quieter and
quieter all the time but
in uh but it's good and there's a part
of me that's thankful for
for for that voice because i don't know
it kind of represents an evolution and
kind of where i come from
um but
as jesse and i kind of finished the
first meditation we were when we were
kind of walking around we started
talking and i was like
you know it's interesting that because
we've spent a lot of time reflecting on
20 years of marriage and the fact that
we have been through these
these transitions through our life of
both getting married under a certain
understanding of the way the world works
and understanding about what marriage is
about and what a man is and what a woman
is and how that has
evolved over time to where we're at now
and i was thinking about the way that i
the old me would process time in nature
or nature in general right
and of course the background that i come
from
sort of a biblical literalism
[Music]
and that's probably an
oversimplification but essentially
the idea that evolution wasn't true
right that humans were a special
creation
and a separate creation from all of the
rest of creation
we were not related to any of the
animals or any of your plants
other than the fact that we were both
creations of god
and in fact humans were created
to have dominion over nature and to
subdue
nature we're fundamentally different and
nature was kind of created for the glory
of god but also for the glory of man
for man to subdue exercise dominion over
and kind of control right
and it's funny because this woman was
talking about how
there are so few redwoods left compared
to their original footprint
and that's due to man subduing
the earth literally cutting down
billions of these trees yeah like there
was a map that showed like the original
footprint of the redwoods and now what's
left and it's just a very very small
fraction
logging you know is one of the big
things you see this thousand-year-old
giant tree and you're like you see
you know 50 houses that you could build
with that or whatever and that's what
man has been doing for a long time and
then of course more recently with
continuing to pull all the fossil fuels
out of the earth and burn them and
climate change is happening and that's
only
further bringing about conditions that
are going to make the redwoods difficult
to
to live through so there will probably
probably at some point be the last
redwood because of the way
humans are subduing the earth right
sounds like your meditation was an
existential crisis
well it wasn't a crisis and i'm gonna
get to why i'm thankful and
grateful and
i was like man i i'm i'm you know
i'm grateful i'm very grateful
that i believe in evolution i'll just be
to be frank
right because of the the
not only do am i grateful because i
think now that you know
now that i understand what it is for
many years i was
arguing against something that i didn't
fully understand it was a
misrepresentation of what the facts were
about this
and it's not just cool that i'm like
okay i believe
something that is more correct
understanding of the way the world works
that's cool
but it's actually there's a deeper and
more significant truth
to it all in my
literal relationship to these trees
right
we're from the same stuff and not like
we're literally related not just related
because we're all from god but we're
literally related we come from the same
place
and of course even more so with the
animals right
but there was just something about that
connection that i was like
it's just cool that there's this
evolution that has happened over the
course of
millennia but then there's also this
personal evolution that has happened
inside inside of me and then i'm
thinking and i'm experiencing all this
in my 20-year anniversary with jesse
who has also gone through this evolution
there's the different versions of jesse
and the different versions of of
me that have kind of gone through all
these stages yeah
and also it i mean this is this is kind
of wild but
jesse and i were talking about because i
think that the evolution has been really
significant
for me but it's been even more
significant for jessie because of
what
because of the way she sees herself
differently as a woman
right because you think about the early
the beginning of our marriage
where the understanding was you know we
read that passage from ephesians at our
wedding like
many christians do that's basically
about wives submitting to your husbands
right and
and and there's this this idea in a
certain brand of christianity
that that women exist for the glory of
men right and that god is the head of
the family but the man is the head of
the household and the woman's primary
role
is to support and help her husband
she's to be quiet in church she's she's
not to teach she used to listen
and when you're a woman things that men
that women can't do that men can do
and there's things that men don't want
to do that's kind of what it seems like
well but the interesting thing is jessie
is really
there's this is this this sort of
turning upside down over world view
for for me as a straight white dude who
was already pretty well positioned
within the church
like i don't there's not like a sudden
empowerment that has happened by
by leaving the church i was already
pretty empowered right
yeah i experienced freedom but i haven't
experienced more empowerment
because of that was a pretty sweet gig
but the idea
that and not to get to like professorial
or talk about history or whatever but
this idea that when you know what i once
thought was an idea that was from god
and was from god's word and that's why
it was important and it was like well
women fulfilling this role in men
fulfilling this role is a good thing
because this is god's plan this is how
he designed it
and now seeing it as no actually the
reason that this is the way that this is
presented in the bible
is because of the history of humanity
and the way our culture has
evolved you know pre-agriculture
when you know
basically before the concept of
ownership right there was a point in
human history
where ownership and owning land didn't
exist
but when agriculture came around the
concept of ownership came along with it
in order for it to function and women
unfortunately got wrapped up in this
concept of ownership and they were
literally owned
and they've been trying to break out of
that patriarchal view of things for a
really long time and there's still a lot
of residual effects and it's more
is still more prevalent in certain parts
of the world but
to see
jesse kind of come to these realizations
that
uh in in the context of this
conversation of like seeing what that
sort of masculine subduing of the earth
of ripping the trees up and drilling for
the oil and
burning the gas and all that stuff to
see
what it's done to the earth yeah uh
and what it's done to women right and
then to see
um
i mean jesse did a good good job talking
about this on her
her twitter account of course because
this is she does a good job of
uh putting this into work so she did a
better job than me so you should you can
go to her
you can go to her twitter account and
see how she has kind of been processing
this but
um
ultimately what i'm trying to say is
that i was very grateful
uh for for her sake
of her having honestly gotten out
of that way of thinking about herself
yeah
and to just i mean it's it's been it's
been a long process but it's great to
love somebody and then see them
become more of themselves to have that
to have that freedom and to
to have that empowerment and it's like
i'm i'm
you know it's like i'm sure she's i'm
sure she loves you for being so
supportive and and and welcoming that
because you certainly don't have to that
doesn't have to be your response
i mean it's just the story of
both of our marriages and relationships
is that like
we've changed so much and
um we've asked so much of our wives
at every turn yeah even even not within
the worldview stuff but within the
career stuff and all that
like so it's it's nice better late than
never
it's it's kind of how i feel about it a
lot of times whenever like
chris and i engage in this is well
because sometimes you can start thinking
about well what do we miss
right right and i and i yeah i want to
be clear but you have this beautiful
moment where she's
able to uh
to be empowered yeah and i want to be
clear that like i don't
i know that if when i talk about this
stuff if you're you know you still
consider yourself a christian or that
you
you subscribe to like a biblical
worldview you're like oh he just thinks
he's better than us and
now and it's like no not that's not
that's not what i think you know
it's like that's where i come from
that's what i believed with all my heart
at one point
i didn't believe it because i was a bad
person i didn't believe it because i was
a bigot
i didn't believe it because i was stupid
uh i believed it because it was what i
was taught um
but in the same way that i i think that
there is a
there is this valuing of sort of stasis
and consistency you know you've got
and and from a christian worldview one
of the attributes of god is this
immutability of god god does not change
at all and that's something that we
really
value in god and so the translation or
the implication is that
that should be true of people you know
and change change is
not great you want us you want you want
to establish your principles and you
want to stick to them and you don't want
to stay the same
but we live in the context of
this evolution that has happened over
the the entire universe the universe
doesn't make sense without the process
of evolution i'm not just talking about
evolution that's taking place on this
earth i'm talking about the principle of
evolution
of of the universe unfolding
and changing over the course of time it
is a fundamental principle
of the way the world works and when you
can kind of
get in tune with that when you can kind
of appreciate it step in line with it
and be like
that process of things unfolding and
things changing is something that's
happening
in individuals as well and it's
something that's awesome
it's it's awesome to witness in somebody
that that you love and it's awesome to
experience personally
so it's not that i'm trying to judge
people who are in a different place
i'm just saying i'm grateful that
there's been not
there's been an evolution in our lives
in that
jesse and i have been able to be walking
side by side through it
of course next week may erase all of
this if because
they felt that she filled out her survey
before your meditation
so you might right you might want to
give her a call before we yeah
that's next week we go through the
answers that they gave to the survey
that they were given
yeah it's great to be married for 20
21 years and to like to
to have such meaningful experiences that
are just focused on
our you know me and christy are you and
jesse and then you have those things
that you take away and like
how you spend that time together and you
have this you're deeply impacted by it
it's just that says so much about your
relationship
and for christie and it's like we were
just talking about like we had as much
fun like that day by the pool
as we've ever had in our marriage like
we were
you know it's it and our whole time
there
you know it was just like i'm so
grateful that we
that we enjoy each other as much as we
ever have
and just kind of had that feeling of
like it's only good flashbacks to newly
being newlyweds in terms of the
excitement of being together and then
like
but then the payoff of of uh
knowing each other yeah so deeply that's
what jesse jesse and i said that our
20-year trip
the week of our 20-year trip was
significantly better than our honeymoon
oh god
so much better yeah it was such a such a
reward
yeah i mean you know that's it's the
payoff for
all all the work that they put in
sticking with us okay before we wrap up
i do have a
relevant uh uh recommendation it's a
book that i read
uh while i was on vacation um how to not
get a boner oh i'm sorry that's
it's called the overstory by richard
powers
and i will say that i was going to
recommend this before i heard barack
obama recommend it on ezra klein's
podcast
okay so i'm not trying to just be like
obama here you talk about dick powers
dick powers dick power uh richard powers
wrote this
uh it won the pulitzer prize it's the
new york times bestseller but it's
essentially speaking of trees it was
just i just happened to pick this up at
a bookstore
in big sur but it is essentially a
collection of stories that center around
trees and peoples in
individual or family sort of
interactions
with trees like there's a tree that is a
and usually a different species of tree
that is a central element of this like
short story in a collection that's kind
of
huh and it sounds weird and it's so
innovative and it is a little bit weird
and innovative is it new
uh it's relatively new i don't know okay
when this thing was written
not too long ago uh 2018. uh
i highly recommend it the overstory um
by richard powers all right
we'll speak at you next week you rich
[ __ ]
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left
and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]